not only is this the most versatile and
Powerful battery that can run almost
anything you want to plug in but it's
got a 4.9 star average customer review
rating and it is on sale for the lowest
price I've ever seen now I've been using
the Delta Pro for over three months now
so I'll be answering some of your guys's
top questions and sharing both the
positives and the negatives of this
insane battery system first off I want
to be honest with you guys and let you
know that we get an insane amount of
companies that want to send us stuff and
I've personally said no to most of those
because their products are not good but
when ecoflow reached out and they wanted
to partner with us and I looked into
what they offer and how much better it
is than stuff that I have personally
bought I said all right let's go ahead
and check it out see how well it does
and overall it has blown away my
expectations and I'll explain why
starting out one of the most important
things is the longevity of this battery
because if you're gonna spend the money
you want it to last and you want it to
last a long time and most brands don't
really want to talk about this because
theirs don't you can completely drain
this Delta Pro every single day which by
the way can charge an iPhone 14 about
300 times on one charge or an M2 MacBook
Air about 70 times on one charge and
after draining it every single day for
10 years you will still have about 80
percent of the original capacity
remaining which is about seven times
better longevity than most other
large-scale batteries like this on the
market and after 20 years you will still
have about 50 percent of the original
capacity that is insanely good and
that's because ecoflow is using the same
LPF Battery tech that Teslas use which
is way more sustainable and
environmentally friendly as well now
because of how long they last some
people are actually using them not only
for home backup but to actually save on
their electricity bill since they can
charge him while the electricity is
cheaper off peak hours and then use it
during the time they would be billed
more now before I give you guys all the
features and the specs I want to tell
you how and what I have been using it
for first off I really wanted one of
these for camping now we absolutely love
going out camping with the family we
have this trailer that makes it really
easy and convenient for our kids
especially with their skin issues being
outside in the tent with dust makes it
so we don't go camping which we didn't
do for many years now some of the spots
that we go to don't have power hookups
you're off grid and the fact that this
thing has a full-size RV hookup is
amazing because not only can we run
things like lights turn on the heaters
for our Dragon it can also run things
like the microwave and even the AC which
won't run off of the trailer batteries
themselves and those also drained
extremely quickly this is made so we
don't really have to worry about going
out and having the power to run things
that we need and also using the app you
can see everything and I'll talk about
that in just a bit with that the Delta
Pro can actually charge your Tesla or
another EV with the right adapter which
is absolutely crazy previously I showed
off the Delta II which is a smaller
scale battery that is powerful but it
does not have that 30 amp so it can't do
things like the AC and that works great
I showed off you know being able to move
it and we were making waffles boiling a
kettle all of those kind of things and
of course the ecoflow Delta Pro can do
all of that as well but it just has a
much bigger capacity which we'll talk
about now some of the other uses that
I've been doing with this other than
going camping is at my house I've been
working on the playground that you guys
have seen my kids are absolutely
enjoying that but that thing is about
150 feet away from any Outlet so I have
to have multiple extensions tied then I
have to remove them put them back up and
moving this thing over with its built-in
handle is very easy it has wheels that
it can roll and So lately I've been
building up this actual play structure
and so I brought out my air compressor
plugged it in and because the air
compressor turns on builds up pressure
and turns off I mean I can use this
thing uh just one charge for multiple
days of doing work and it runs
everything without any issues or any
hassle it is extremely convenient now it
also has a bunch of other ports so I'm
not limited with what I want to connect
to it and I'll let you guys know how
long this battery lasts for a lot of
different appliances in just a bit now
at home the other major reason why I
wanted it is because it taken back up
your house if the power goes out as well
now outside I actually have a hookup for
a generator and hooks up to 20 with a
switch on my breaker box hooking up the
Delta Pro I can get off of grid power if
it's out and the select which Breakers I
want to be on so if I want to run
multiple different rooms I want to run
lights my refrigerator even my stove now
you can actually power multiple of these
together that gives you a lot more power
and up to six of them with a smart home
breaker kit saving power and monitoring
which is really cool now the build
quality is also great you have this
plastic case but is extremely durable
now the front we have a bunch of
connections starting out with four
regular 110 volt ports 20 amps Max so
you can connect any accessories any
Chargers whatever you want you can run
an extension from there if you want to
plug something in and then we also to
have that very powerful 30 amp
connection like I showed you for the RV
we have four USB type A ports two of
them are standard and the other two are
designed for smartphones tablets because
they have fast charging they can adjust
their voltage to maximize that as well
as two USBC ports that offer up to 100
watts output that means even with a 14
inch MacBook Pro you can get fast
charging to get to 50 in 30 minutes with
those ports and like I said the empty
MacBook Air you can charge at about 70
times from one charge Now hidden on the
side here we have a bunch of other
outputs you have a barrel plug we have
this 12 volt 30 amp output at the top as
well as the smaller Barrel plugs to hook
up different accessories and then we
have some switches uh we have a remote
control that can plug into here if you
want to see everything at a distance if
you're tucking these away okay there's a
lot of options now to charge this thing
you also have a ton of options of course
you can plug it into a regular wall
outlet and it will fully charge in 2.7
hours that is extremely fast for a
battery that is this capacity a regular
MacBook takes about that long to charge
now along with that you can actually
charge it in as low as 1.8 hours if you
combine different options so for example
you can actually charge this with solar
panels I'll talk about the one that I
have you could also charge it from a car
with that outlet you can combine
multiple ones and you can actually
charge this at an EV station with an
adapter that you can get from them so
that is really fast as well so as far as
charging there are no issues they also
have a dual fuel Smart generator which
you can plug in and the reason that it's
smart is that it will actually turn on
automatically it communicates with this
so as soon as the battery is is low at
whatever level you want it will kick and
automatically charge it up it'll
actually boost the wattage if you're
pulling at the same time and then shut
itself off and you don't have to use
just gasoline you can run it off of
propane which has a better shelf life
it's a lot more convenient in many cases
it's less expensive and that is really
convenient because you can have one of
these it won't die and you have
continuous power now this thing could be
a solar generator as well I have a 220
watt bifocal solar panel and that means
that not only does it have 220 watts of
cylinder in the front it actually has
155 Watts on the back side and when you
set it up it can actually pick up extra
power or extra solar that was lost and
so when it bounces up for example
concrete works really well but even on
grass it will pick up extra energy from
the Sun and convert that which is really
cool but you can hook up a bunch of
different solar air actually is
compatible with up to 90 percent of the
solar that's on the market and with the
compatible panels you could charge this
from 5.6 hours all the way down to 2.8
hours just from free energy from the sun
which is really sweet they also have
this insane solar panel mount kit that
will actually move the panel and adjust
to get the optimal amount of energy from
the Sun now as far as the capacity this
thing has
3600 Watt hours of battery capacity now
I showed off the Delta 2 that has about
a thousand and then I expanded it with
the second battery giving me 2 000 but
this thing has 3600 and it can reach up
to 25 000 Watt hours when you hook it up
the using the full system and the smart
panel to your house now as far as power
output like I said it has 3600 watt
standard and with X boost it can go up
to 4500 and has a surge rating of 7 2001
if something spikes up and of course you
can also double that if you connect two
of these bad boys together now another
question you guys have asked is how long
will this last for using various
appliances well on their website they
have this cool tool that will give you
all the info for example for a light
that is 10 watts which is actually quite
a bit higher than a standard LED at
about six you'll get 337 hours if you're
connected over DC which is more
efficient if you have a CPAP machine
that will run about 50 hours to run a TV
you get about 27 hours a coffee maker
you'll get about 3.3 hours now I know
that doesn't sound like a lot same thing
with the microwave at two and a half
hours but you're not gonna be
microwaving for two and a half hours
long when I was using a kettle that also
uses a lot of power but you're done in
just a few minutes when you're drawing
that power because it's sufficient it's
very fast so in reality if you're going
camping you're running things like a
blender other things that's going to
last multiple days because you don't
have it on now I showed you guys if
you're charging up a phone about 300
times in a laptop right here 57 times
for a 60 watt hour of course like a
MacBook Air has a smaller battery than
that so even with just one it does last
a long time and you guys should go and
read the reviews as how some of these
professional people are using this for a
saw and a jackhammer they have very very
good points and experience with it now I
also want to show you guys the app
because it is extremely powerful and
very handy to have that really matters
if you're buying one of these tap
something that is designed well not
something that lacks features so here
you can just go ahead and add the Delta
Pro this thing has both Bluetooth and
Wi-Fi so even if you're somewhere where
you don't have Wi-Fi you'll still
connect be able to get all your info on
the home page I could see the capacity
of the Delta Pro the temperature I also
have the full info for the input
obviously nothing's plugged in but we
see all the different charging methods
and a little graph for the outputs I can
actually toggle the AC ports on and off
you guys hear that right now bam it
kicked on I could turn it off also the
barrel plug and that the other output on
the side all of my USB ports I can see
what wattage they're outputting it is so
nice to see that now we can go into the
settings and I'll briefly go through all
of this I can adjust the discharge level
so if I don't want it to charge more
than 80 or lower than certain speed I
could do that with the AC charging I can
also bump that up bam to 1800 watts we
have our car input the screen brightness
the smart generator when you want that
thing to kick on to recharge it you have
full adjustability this app has been
extremely handy when I'm inside at night
in the RV I've opened it up I can see
what level the charge is at and I can
actually shut it off without having to
go outside so that if I don't don't need
to charge up the batteries anymore or
run anything I can save power I can turn
it on remotely as well it has been
awesome so overall this thing has been
amazing but what are the downsides well
first off it is not cheap now it is
priced better than the competition while
having better features very fast
charging and the longevity that this
thing is going to last a very very long
time but you still have to spend some
money and with that this has a ton of
storage capacity so it is heavy it's
about 99 pounds now you do have that
handle so you can pull it easily I even
pulled it through grass that was not an
issue so I'm very glad they added it if
it was just the handles themselves that
would be a pain you'd have to get into
their wagon like you do with some of the
other ones but when it does come time to
lift it up be aware that this thing is
not as light as the Delta twos that I
showed off previously other than that I
really have no other other complaints
you guys saw based off of the reviews
people absolutely love these it's a lot
of value so if you're looking for
something that can power an RV can back
up your home and even with the adapter
charge an electric vehicle just in case
you run out of power I would take a look
at one of these they're very versatile
very powerful so there you guys go go
ahead and check out the links in the
description as a heads up ecoflow is
having a Black Friday campaign soon from
November 11th to the 28th it's going to
be one of the best times to buy and the
reason I didn't mention price is because
the price is variable and for their
products they'll have up to 50 percent
off and with that if you're going to be
buying multiple products the more money
you spend you're going to get free gifts
that get better and better so if you
want to buy a couple of these pairing
them together or anything else go ahead
and check out those links below and the
deals that they have thank you guys for
watching click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there if you have any
questions asked down below this is Max
and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]